ok the next question came in from
Mauritius where youtubers who are
looking to use data to make important
changes in their business for 2016 what
metrics should they be paying attention
to most thank you so much great I feel
like this is one that you should cover
because you probably know way more than
I possibly could but i will say before
heading it off to evan because he is the
expert in this um it's my understanding
that a lot of YouTube analytics are the
same as google analytics so if they were
me now not Evan but if it were me I'd be
looking at email sessions that come in
the impressions that were given the time
spent watching the video any type of
consumer action that happened during
that time I would consider that my KPI
or my you know the bar and I'm
constantly trying to be jumped that bar
is what I'm doing but Evan please I
lived here okay so with YouTube watch
time is the most important variable in
their system if you have high watch time
on your videos then you will get ranked
higher and it's not just watched I'm on
a particular video it's then their
entire session so YouTube wants you to
stay on youtube as long as possible 24
hours a day so if you come and watch one
of my videos then you leave my channel
and watch 10 hours of Justin Bieber I
get credit for all those 10 hours too
and so that's YouTube's goal and if you
look at your analytics now they recently
changed the back end where watch time is
number one thing that you see it's the
first box when you log into your YouTube
back end it used to be views and now
it's so it's watched time and so if
you're doing a deep dive on your videos
you could look at one series versus
another and i know mauritius channel a
little bit she has different series she
has like whatever wednesdays what I was
Wednesdays and she'll do some singing
videos what you can do is compare those
two series right take videos in those
series and compare the watch time on
them not the absolute watch time but the
relative watch time so if you're singing
video is five minutes long it'll show
you how it compares to other five minute
videos on YouTube and you'll see if
you're above or below the average and if
you're below then what
you didn't make it better right how do
you I don't know sing better or bring in
friends or pick different songs or maybe
don't continue that series right so I'll
always track you know I track my daily
daily and kind of obsessed have this
excel file and I'll check my subscribers
and I'll track my number of views on the
channel I would have to say that oven if
you're keeping an excel file we should
partner up I'm telling you right now
because that's that's my lucky you keep
excel files too I like it but yeah but
like ended on an individual video basis
watch time is going to be the most
important thing